bon il faut qu'on ait une petite
discussion là il se passe quoi avec les
pubs pour jeux mobiles là sur les
réseaux l'élément déclencheur de cette
vidéo parlons-en ya toujours un élément
déclencheur commence à connaître tu me
balade sur un stade il ya des meufs en
legging il ya des mecs bodybuildé il ya
des gens qui voyagent très cool il ya
des artistes photos sympas et entre tout
ça dans mon fils je school je tourne sur
ça et qu'est ce que c'est que ce débute
plus on est où là
franchement au début je me suis dit
[ __ ] c'est une pub leroy merlin genre
pour la nouvelle scie sauteuse leroy
merlin y lançant une tous les six ans
ils font la promo à chaque fois qu'il a
ce soir je me dis [ __ ] c'est logique
mais d'un autre côté quel erreur qu'un
spam propose à moi une pub pour un truc
de bricolage
quelle erreur de ciblage je me dis
attendent un enfant ce n'est pas
possible et grande surprise c'est une
pub pour un jeu mobile mais ils font
genre que voilà un mec si son téléphone
et ça a marché sur moi donc j'ai la
haine parce qu'il mourut avec leur
mécanique de fond blanc et ensuite c'est
quoi ça non mais on est où là
ça m'a rappelé youtube en 2013 quand
vous êtes tous des miniatures mégawatts
à qui avec des titres megabit à cliquer
pour attirer les gens et le contenu
n'était pas du tout ce à quoi tu
t'attendais en cliquant c'est dans la
même chose puisque le jeu il est pas au
fond ce qui conçoit honey ça désolé si
vous l'avez des ailes bref la plus en
plus de mécanique qui sont utilisés par
les boîtes de jeux mobiles pour attirer
l'attention du mec qui tombe sur la pub
dans les une ou deux premières secondes
on s'en fout que ça corresponde à la
réalité aux produits qu'on met en avant
on veut juste que le mec soit curieux et
clique c'est vraiment ça la strate c'est
bon ça il ya des mécaniques folle comme
la scie sauteuse dans le téléphone moi
j'avais pitié pour le téléphone quand
j'ai vu ça ok tout d'abord laissez moi
vous parler de wisches
oui je crois que c'est un site qui vend
1 milliards d'objets très made in china
mais j'en rêverai prix du made in china
donc très peu cher je crois pas qu'ils
soient du drop shipping j'en sais rien
je connais pas tout ce que je connais de
ceux-ci de ces annonces et leur
technique c'est de mettre dans ton fidh
en poste sponsorisés du coup en pub le
produit le plus improbable pas du tout
un produit qui va t'intéresser pas du
tout juste un produit tu connais pas et
on voit l'image tu dis mais c'est quoi
ça et tu cliques mec
regardez moi ça c'est quoi faire ça
ressemble à un slip mais ça se met sur
la têt du chat
quel est le but de mathias sur la tête
de souche à gboguhé en fait c'est juste
une muselière pour charmer là ce n'est
plus une muselière mec c'est juste on
chasse de vie plus il veut mourir une
muselière ça empêche juste la bouche de
souffrir tu vois mais le chien voix sans
est tous là c'est comme si je te mettais
un oreiller sur la tête jusqu'à la fin
de ta vie c'est terrible là on ne
comprend même pas
ce qu'ils vendent 1 euro quoi un chat
des plantes pas ouf
un morceau de béton je sais même pas si
c'est ça qui est fou le ciblage le
franchement mec je tombe sur cette pub
franche je suis pas bien avec toutes les
données là qu'ils ont eue sur moi c'est
ça qui me propose à la fois c'est un
d'urinoirs pour enfants c'est au riz
mais qu ils sont vraiment c'est cet
objet aurait amené carter deux doigts ça
se dit probablement comme ça je sais pas
les gens font les guitaristes cela dit
moi ça existe ou pas pour de vrai le but
c'est d'écarter les doigts pour que tu
que tu es encore derrière en gros tient
devient difformes
mais tu seras bon guitare t'inquiète
qu'il est pour les ips être l'objet en
fait je trouve ya une vraie différence
entre proposé ça comme objet sur son
site et mettre ce même objet mais en
poste sponsorisés payer pour que les
gens voient cet objet dans leur fidh ces
incroyables mec je comprend l'utilité de
0,2 ces objets et scarna ubs que c'est
juste moi qui suis inculte et ce genre
là il ya plein de gens parmi vous qui
disent mais attendant les petites
chaînes qu'on met sur l'ongle au hockey
quand même lucas était un culte à but
c'est ce que je comprend déjà plus le
monde qui m'entoure je sais pas mais
c'est vrai que je suis et une vidéo pour
parler de ces pubs je me remets vraiment
en question cela attendait ça y est
moins bien de me faire avoir là j'ai
envie de l'acheter trop pratique mais
c'est pour jouer toutes les petits
poussière et les petites saletés qui
traînent dans ses recoins inaccessibles
à dans ta voiture si léger excusez moi
ça y est vous regardez 8 sur 10 c'est
bon j'ai tout compris à l'instant en
fait l'île m 10 objets improbables mais
y en a forcément un sur les dix qui va
nous toucher nous tout cela peut-être
qu'au moment où je parle certains
d'entre nous la sont en train de
commander les carters de doit tout
simplement vous dire mieux c'est des
temps c'est des [ __ ] de domec
probablement fausse mais quand même
pourquoi comment quoi il met des verts
mec s'est redressé pour ce conte des
bestioles c'est pour nourrir les
bestioles mais quand t'as pas de
bestiole est un peu la phobie des verts
qui plus est horrible les premières fois
je tombais sur les plus bullish je me
suis dit [ __ ] je me suis remis en
question
je me suis dit attends mais mon
historique est vraiment si sombre et
étrange je mérite vraiment des pubs
comme ça pour ça moi attends attends à
l'embl actuellement critique plus la wii
châtain c'est un pantalon qui retient
les odeurs de paix foire qui achètent ça
il faut vraiment qu'ils au bailleur est
dit
yar est dit walf à couy ch merci wish
pour la discrétion
ag faris de beauf mais au style rien le
plus beau jeu de la chaîne sur l'image
la plus pauvre de la chaîne waouh hockey
/ wish bon c'est vraiment l'endroit de
l'arnaqué il ya des fois des annonces où
il joue sur les fameuses android vendu
télé à 3 euros tu la commande terreau
fais-tu d'ivoire alors du cirque or là
et tu reçois une télé miniature très
petit et inutilisable mais dans le titre
de la non s'il n'y avait pas marqué
miniature est inutilisable est marquée
tuer
quelle arnaque mike dans cette jungle de
pub qu'on se mange tous les jours tous
le but c'est de se faire remarquer c'est
que ta pub à toi soit remarqué plus que
celle du voisin et donc du coup il ya
une sorte d' escalade comme ça dans la
dans la connerie et ça m'arrivait note
de taper des fous rires les prochaines
mec c'est celle que je me tape beaucoup
en ce moment c'est les pubs pour les
jeux un choix comme linda brown mais
c'est de la folie ils te mettent les
paires situations de la vie avec les
paires choix possible pour que tu
télécharges le pire jeu exemple j'ai cru
entendre un bruit
oh là là on fait quoi
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce jeu si je vais je vais
accoucher où est mon mari
il est avec ma gynéco c'est une blague
entrée partir que j'ai pas compris qu
est-ce que vous choisirez vous contrôler
ce qui se passe en ans je vais péter
retient toi peut-être qu'elle aimera ça
ça c'est une annonce pour moi par
exemple c'est comme le pantalon jeudi
ndiaye sa soeur coup de foudre
la plage gay rien que ça un homme que
dois je faire maintenant je m'enterre
dans le sable où je les embrasse
passionnément
c'est comme ça que j'ai fait trois
vidéos sur linda bras bon ça c'était les
jeux ea choix qui sont elles sont dans
mon top 3 des préfets maintenant je vous
parle de la larnack la plus totale
c'est lily ce gardien c'est un [ __ ] de
kent dick roche light ou faut aligner
l'aller les mêmes symboles machin vous
connaissait et leur pub non
rien à voir avec ça
bon
[Musique]
bourgeois qui dit qu ils prennent part
les sentiments light se tiennent comme
ça pour tailler des lili mais tu vas pas
l'aider tu vas payer 10 euros pour
aligner trois lignes de plus en arrêter
de nous faire culpabiliser [ __ ] il l a
jamais été enceinte mais ce qui est
dingue avec cette pub là c'est que en
fait il ya eu tellement un bad buzz
autour de ça en mode mais les gars vous
avez craqué vous qui suit vous arrive
que la boîte a dû réagir et ils ont créé
une fin qui n'étaient pas là dans la
vidéo originale d'armance à se terminer
quand elle pleure sur les marches et ils
ont rajouté
[Musique]
incroyable pas du coup là le titre celis
garden la pub entière mais en fait non
la pub entière s'était bien ce qu'on a
vu avant juste ils se sont rattrapés
c'est incroyable j'ai pas même celle là
[Musique]
mec c'est quoi ce bordel là et ça vous
allez publier plus beau possible pour
que les gens jouent à notre kent dick
roche en un peu moins bien que kenzy
grrrr la mécanique facebook elle est
marrante parce qu'en gros à elle flatte
l'ego genre vraiment elle flatte l'ego
style si vous êtes vraiment intelligent
vous y arriverez et seuls 3 % des
joueurs y arrive
voilà exactement ça les personnes ayant
accueilli 240 peuvent trouver les
différences au niveau 98 attendait un
enfant deux ans trouvent les différents
cela bon le dernier vous le connaissez
c'est devenu un mème début 2019
ces mafias city mais je suis sûr que
vous avez vous n'êtes pas avoir vu
matthias ti personne ne l'a jamais
téléchargé vous savez c'est les pubs
genre level 1 ce billard level 10 cook
level 50 boss et le but c'est de devenir
le boss et du coût de leur public crée
des situations le niveau 1 devient level
60 par exemple bosse encore une fois
c'est des pubs qui reflète du tout le
jeu auxerre le gameplay du jeu c'est ce
à quoi c'est pareil tu fais ta ville
machin il ya des gars examen comme le
jeu d'avants avec les mecs en question
c'est la même chose mais à une autre
époque comme cette mécanique la du level
un machin level 60 boss elle a tellement
marché qu'il ya des compilations sur
youtube des pubs de mafia city qui dure
plus de 30 minutes
les mecs ont fait des centaines de pub
mais je veux trop devenir le mail 35
bosse vraiment
et
oh c'est devenu à 2099 boss mai
[Musique]
il est devenu violent il étouffe du
blanc le mail 60 on est plus noir ou
mais blanc on a des privilèges qu'il
faut l'imec
[Musique]
wahhab est à toi je veux être un level
30 mafia boss mec je veux que les
polices il salua multiples reprises
le pire c'est que c'est malin je sais
vraiment malin je comprends pourquoi des
gens qui ont été chargés qu'on joue et
ça attise tellement ta curiosité que tu
as envie de cech quoi je veux être
nouvelle 60 ans chez vous quand vous
voyez dans la rue maintenant s'il vous
plaît en fait des fois je me dis ça mais
le temps et l'énergie qui met là pour
concevoir et faire leur pub où il ya de
la 3d et tout mais [ __ ] mais mettez le
dans votre jeu quoi il était le bordel y
aura peut-être besoin de moins de pub
pour qui marche du coup le bouche à
oreille fera son effet genre après j'ai
pas de jeux mobiles donc j scolaire bon
écoutez j'ai dit ce que j'avais à dire
sur les pubs de jeux mobiles mais
continuez continuez les développeurs
continuent à nous régaler un stack
continue à me proposer régulièrement
j'adore en fait c'est marrant puisqu'il
a même pas de règle qui impose aux gens
de faire des pubs qui correspondent aux
produits qu'ils proposent un jeu ou un
site ou acheter des objets j'aime son
qui a aucune règle et du coup le but
c'est vraiment juste d'attirer
l'attention de la personne
coûte que coûte et qu'une partie de
l'entreprise qu'à la mort soit dédié à
la création de mécanique qui attire les
gens sur les pubs de la boîte gorge ça
vraiment impressionnant pourquoi j'ai un
tour de vis dans la main et je fais ça
remet en même temps que je parle je sais
pas étrange je vous dis à très vite dans
une prochaine vidéo et j'espère que cela
vous serez un level cardon devos mais
quoi
[Musique]